[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous je dis 23 novembre
bienvenue dans le 7-8 journal sur tv 78
tout de suite les titres de l'actualité
locale
une opération qui détourne les codes du
black friday pour consommer autrement le
green friday se déroule jusqu'à samedi
proposée par l'association envie attrape
des animations ont débuté une l'abri
solidaire était par exemple proposé ce
matin aux habitants nous étions sur
place
initier les plus jeunes à la robotique
principe du rambo jane qui revient pour
sa deuxième édition grâce à l'aide
d'étudiants en industrie de montigny le
bretonneux et des élèves yvelinois
apprennent à programmer des robots dans
l'optique de participer à une
compétition focus dans cette édition
et puis c'est un art martial qui nous
vient directement du brésil la capoeira
sera au programme ce week end les 15ème
rencontre internationale se tiennent à
elancourt samedi pour en parler un
maître de la discipline maistre touché
est notre invité avec deux de ses élèves
mais tout de suite nous sommes en ligne
avec philippe ghislain par téléphone
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le président
de l'union des maires ruraux des
yvelines vous êtes également le maire de
méricourt
vous avez suivi
il ya un instant donc le discours d'
emmanuel macron qui s'est achevé il y à
peu le président de la république s'est
exprimé devant les élus locaux en
clôture du 100ème congrès des maires de
france c'était à paris emmanuel macron
abordé de nombreux sujets bien sûr il ya
il a tenté de rassurer les élus
principale annonce le président de la
république a annoncé une refonte totale
de la fiscalité locale au niveau
régional départemental et également
communal les travaux seront remis fin
2018 mise en oeuvre en 2000 2020 c'est
une refonte nécessaire pour vous cette
cette fiscalité locale il fallait il
fallait la réforme et oui oui je pense
qu'on avait besoin de réformer cette
fiscalité pour redonner redonner aux
communes une certaine autonomie et puis
une certaine vision puisqu'on va vers la
suppression comme il l'a annoncée de la
taxe d'habitation non plus pour 80 mais
peut-être pour cent pour cent des
français
effectivement en partant du principe que
la taxe était injuste on aura besoin
d'instaurer l'impôt beaucoup plus juste
et b qui permettent de regarder les
faits de l'autonomie à nos communes
vous parliez justement la taxe dhabi
d'habitation ça sera l'une des premières
étapes en de cette refonte la
suppression de cette taxe d'habitation
pour les ménages c'est un levier de
moins pour les communes emmanuel macron
a rappelé néanmoins avec eux cette
suppression serait compensée par en
intégralité donc 10 milliards d'euros
financée par des économies de l'état est
ce que vous êtes rassurés par par cette
annonce ce qu'on pense à cette
compensation annoncée par le président
de la république va rassurer l'état nous
a déjà fait le coup à plusieurs reprises
moi j'entends cela dit le président
j'aurais tendance à vouloir lui faire
confiance mais ça va être un écran
selon pardon c'est peut-être un écran de
fumée pour vous j'espère que qu'il
tiendra ses promesses moi ce qui
m'inquiète c'est l'alternance politique
je pense que le présent macron tiendra
ses promesses jusqu'à la fin de son
mandat mais lorsqu'il y aura alternance
voilà on pourra revenir dessus
moi j'aurais préféré que je souhaiterais
que ce soit inscrit dans le marbre de
manière à ce que les communes en général
et une visibilité à très long terme
aujourd'hui c'est ce qui nous pose
problème en des projets on en a plein
on peut trouver des solutions mais
n'ayant pas de visibilité on n'ose plus
aujourd'hui lancer nos projets merci
philippe gesland avoir été avec nous je
le rappelle vous êtes le président de
l'union des maires ruraux des yvelines
au revoir dans l'actualité également la
mobilisation des agents techniques du
conseil départemental il conteste le
souhait de la collectivité
d'externaliser ses missions de
restauration et d'entretien des collèges
autrement dit ah les yvelines ne
gérerait plus directement ses missions
et les agents craignent pour leur avenir
800 personnes seraient concernées selon
la cgt et fo une heure de grève a donc
été observée jeudi dernier et ce midi au
temps de restauration dans les collèges
une nouvelle heure de débrayage est
également prévue jeudi prochain propos
recueillis par nicolas d'android si on
passe au prix au privé il ya une partie
des fonds publics yvance se volatiliser
finalement pour verser des dividendes à
des actionnaires
alors qu'on sait qu'il ya des besoins de
renforts de moyens d'outils de nombre de
couverts de qualité de produits s'ils
veulent investir pour améliorer ils
peuvent le faire on a les moyens dans ce
département
faut qu'ils arrêtent de nous raconte l
inverse l'explication sur le papier
c'est améliorer la qualité des repas
amélioré la qualité des services être
sûr du développement durable mais on est
pour tout ça en plus ça correspond à
strictement rien faire des circuits
courts du bio améliorer la qualité du
repas dans l'est dans les cantines
éviter le gaspillage alimentaire on peut
le faire on sait le faire dans un
service public privatisé c'est pas la
réponse à ces questions là un comité
technique entre les syndicats la
direction du conseil départemental est
prévu le
7 décembre prochain délibération finale
acte et qui sera au programme de de la
séance du conseil départemental prévu le
22 décembre
je vous en parlais dans les titres
aujourd'hui a débuté le green friday une
opération qui contre le black friday ou
des promotions sont proposées lors du
dernier week-end de novembre le green
friday apporte une réflexion sur
l'économie d'usagé a montré que d'autres
modes de consommation existent s'est
organisée par le réseau envie comme ici
à sa boutique est de trappes
elle proposait ce matin une laverie
solidaire explications au micro de
mélanie poquet cette laverie éphémère
est là elle a pour vocation de faire
réfléchir sur ces sujets là les gens
viennent quand ils veulent sur trois
jours un cessez le gris de friday mais
on a élargi un petit peu parce que notre
action merrill bien trois jours pour
faire passer nos messages donc jeudi
vendredi et samedi sur les horaires
d'ouverture du magasin entre 10h et 19h
les gens viennent en libre service
s'ils veulent amener leur linge pour le
laver ou le faire sécher
ils sont bienvenus et pendant ce temps
là on leur propose un parcours
d'animation qui explique à la fois notre
travail de réparation donc en faveur de
l'économie circulaire
et puis le travail d'insertion
professionnelle d'autres animations sont
au programme jusqu'à samedi au magasin
envie de trappes et demain vendredi
l'eurodéputé pascal durand sera de
passage dans cette boutique yvelinoise
on accueille sur ce plateau une invitée
joséphine coleman ce berger bonsoir est
la mère de plaisir alors votre ville a
mis en place un projet
intergénérationnel
objectif affiché lutter contre l'
isolement et privilégier le partage la
tolérance et l'entr'aide on va voir ce
que ça veut dire concrètement dans un
instant car des actions a été votée le
mois dernier en conseil municipal
pourquoi le lien intergénérationnel est
il une priorité pour la ville de plaisir
ça nous semble fondamental aujourd'hui
parce que on se rend compte que l'on vit
de façon un peu sectorisé et il nous
semblait que dans cette démarche
citoyenne parce que j'appelle ça une
démarche citoyenne
il était important qu'on puisse réunir
et apprendre à faire se connaître
différents âges de la population chaque
génération peut apporter à une autre
quelque chose
comment et même des choses très très
intéressante et très structurante alors
des actions concrètes ont été votés en
conseil municipal le 18 octobre dernier
des actions qui ont été le fruit en fait
d'un long processus il ya d'abord eu un
diagnostic établi ça c'était au
printemps dernier six arènes ya eu
quatre mois à peu près de diagnostic
avec tous les partenaires qui existait
déjà sur le territoire de plaisir des
partenaires associatifs mais également
des des choses un petit peu un petit peu
plus institutionnel 200 partenaires je
crois oui exactement et qui ont
travaillé ensemble pour déjà faire un
diagnostic de qu'est ce que c'est que
l'intergénérationnel nalité pardon sur
sûr plaisir mais aussi ailleurs parce
que je dirais que c'est une étude qui
peut être un petit peu général et suite
à ça et bien on en a mis en place trois
axes qui sont des axes fondamentaux
aujourd'hui qui sont les axes sur
lesquels le vent se déployer bien 18
fiches actions qui ont déjà démarré pour
certaines et qui vont démarrer en 2018
c'est ça ça va être déployé sur toute la
fin de votre mandat finalement qui
s'étale jusqu'en 2020 exactement on
avait mis en place déjà un contrat ville
solidarité vous savez on a eu même un
prix deux européen par rapport à ceux
contre aby solidarité et là c'est un
contrat ville intergénérationnel c'est
pas pour avoir des prix avant qu'on fait
ça c'est bien bien sûr pour que
justement les générations puissent se
rencontrer sur des choses très concrètes
pour avoir rencontré pas mal de jeunes
de lycéens et même de collégiens je me
suis rendu compte qu'il y avait une
vraie bienveillance aujourd'hui de cette
génération montante qui avait très envie
d'être en partenariat avec des personnes
en difficulté voire pas en difficulté
mais de partager des choses avec avec
ces personnes plus âgées voire très âgé
et sabam je disais récemment ouvert 7/7
idée qui n'est pas nouvelle mais en tout
cas de créer des liens sur des actions
très spécifiques
alors le diagnostic on l'a dit au
printemps dernier ça a été présenté
d'ailleurs lors d'une réunion au théâtre
robert manuel qui est ce qu il en est
ressorti faire le diagnostic il y avait
des choses à faire ça
il en est ressorti que oui on se
connaissait pas bien et qu'il y avait
beaucoup de choses à faire dans la
mesure où on a ressenti les isolements
on a ressenti beaucoup de puissance
d'action beaucoup de volonté et on s'est
dit et bien on va construire quelque
chose toutes les idées un des dix huit
fiches actions viennent effectivement
des personnes que nous avons rencontrées
salir des jeunes des moins jeunes et des
beaucoup moins jeunes et c'est de là que
sont parties ces actions il ya un
véritable besoin
et puis je crois que ça crée un lien ça
crée un lien social mais un lien aussi
de dynamisme au niveau d'une
collectivité et d'apprendre à voilà ma
vivre ensemble et de créer des choses
ensemble une action concrète voté il ya
eu oui des groupes de travail 1 qui
avait planché sur le diagnostic dont on
a parlé trois grandes thématiques pour
ses 18 fiches actions notamment l'accès
à la culture aux loisirs
oui exactement c'est important parce
qu'on se rend compte que vous avez des
des tranches d'âge qui ne se déplace pas
au théâtre
pas forcément par le biais à la
difficulté financière mais parce que
elles ont besoin d'être accompagnés donc
on s'est dit avec certains jeunes qu'on
pourrait peut-être aller les chercher
faire du covoiturage les accompagner les
inciter à sortir ça c'est dans le cadre
par exemple du théâtre mais ça peut être
sûr des associations ça peut être aussi
sur des cours au niveau de
l'informatique en faillite toute une
série de choses qu'on peut faire comme
ça en binôme par rapport à cet accès est
aussi à la mobilité parce qu'il ya des
personnes qui ont des problématiques de
mobilité donc non seulement la ville
accompagne parce qu'elle a mis en place
aussi quelque chose par rapport à cette
mobilité avec un transport mais il ya
des jeunes et des moins jeunes qui
souhaitent participer à ça on s'est
rendu compte qu'il y avait une vraie
chute aujourd'hui au niveau du bénévolat
dans toutes les associations
ça c'est un vrai moyen citoyens de
revenir à l'aide aux autres faire avec
et faire pour les autres
deux autres priorités on le rappelle
juste entre clôturer cet entretien
favoriser l'investissement citoyens de
chacune des générations également
favorisé
développement des talents petit rappel
nous reste un peu moins d'une minute ou
et sur le calendrier donc là ça a été
des quelques actions sont déjà mises en
place et ça va s'étaler la sueur sur les
prochains mois oui il ya une action sur
laquelle je voudrais juste revenir
trente secondes c'est cette aide pour
les jeunes au permis de conduire c'est à
dire une aide financière par rapport aux
jeunes autour d'un projet parce qu'il
s'agit pas de venir demander une aide
comme ça il faut qu'ils créent un projet
dans ce principe intergénérationnel et
la ville accompagné hauteur de 500 euros
tous les jeunes qui vont nous apporter
un projet qui va dans ce sens merci je
vais parler avec le maire de la ville
qui met en place son projet inter
générationnelle on vous parlait tout à
l'heure d'environnement dans ce journal
avec le green friday c'est en ce moment
aussi la semaine européenne pour la
réduction des déchets et des gestes
simples au quotidien qui permettent de
réduire le gaspillage ou de limiter la
surconsommation au chesnay un village
zéro déchet est justement installé
jusqu'à dimanche prochain
de quoi trouver quelques conseils on
voit tout ça avec camille lambert
[Musique]
une devise pour devenir un consommateur
responsable
voilà le message passé dans ce village
zéro déchet chaque année près de 800
millions de tonnes de déchets sont
produits en france
un constat inquiétant mais avec des
gestes simples chacun peut limiter sa
production qu'il ne fallait pas
gaspiller qu'il fallait trouver des
moyens pour recycler le compass tco
qu'il fallait recycler les choses de
bien faire le tri pour pas polluer ne
pas jeter les choses dehors
l'important une soixantaine d'élèves du
chesnay et de rocquencourt ont écouté
les conseils toute la matinée découverte
des achats en vrac pour éviter le sur
emballage de l'éco conception ou de la
lutte contre le gaspillage alimentaire
plusieurs thématiques abordées avec les
membres de l'association y ça devient
concret il se projette eux dans leur
quotidien avec ses petites façon de
faire c'est qu'ils prennent les bonnes
habitudes les bons réflexes
les bonnes façons d'aborder la
consommation de bien réfléchir avant
d'acheter une première pour versailles
grand parc
la communauté d'agglomération organise
ce village en partenariat avec
l'association et le sictom ca le
syndicat en fait par lequel sont traités
les ordures ménagères notamment des
villas du chéné vélizy et versailles
sont vraiment touchée par cet art ce
sujet par cette thématique est du coup
ça rafraîchit et aussi son véhicule hier
le message auprès des parents aussi
sensibiliser aussi le grand public qui
pourra venir visiter le village jusqu'au
26 novembre à l'hôtel de ville
evènement leur en-but games revient pour
sa deuxième édition une collaboration
entre les étudiants du cfj l'école
d'industrie de montigny le bretonneux et
les établissements scolaires du bassin
des écoles du bassin de rambouillet
l'occasion à d'initier les plus jeunes à
la robotique et au programme
informatique marylène iapichino
pour apprendre un domestique et les
robots le cfj de montigny le bretonneux
ville les écoles primaires et les
collèges du bassin de rambouillet a
participé au grand bosquet le principe
un étudiant en cauchies classes du cm1 à
la quatrième à programmer un robot sur
un parcours avec un objectif final la
compétition dans six mois
c'est d'amener les études un communiqué
une passion pas seulement à travailler à
la programmation du codage de
l'organisation et l'utilisation de
robots mais aussi à considérer
l'environnement de ces robots et
l'environnement c'est l'humain donc pour
eux c'est une expérience humaine avant
que d'être une expérience technique
dira-t-on mardi soir des écoles
découvrit le cahier des charges précis
de cette deuxième édition
le robot devra franchir deux portes
contourner un élément est passée sous un
autre le tout dans un décor sur le thème
de la découverte de l'espace pour les
aider des étudiants aux managers des
systèmes informatique et robotique
je suis impatient de leur montrer la
passion que j'ai pour ça et
éventuellement peut-être les inspirer
pour continuer dans ce domaine là plus
tard l'année dernière le challenge sous
le thème du cirque a connu un succès
auprès des établissements on se classe
participe cette année avec un grand
enthousiasme des élèves qui trouve ça
très intéressant puis ça mélange en pet
plusieurs disciplines annonce qui leur
permet en fait de faire des ponts et des
liens entre chaque et ça leur donne ça
va un peu de temps un peu de concret
dans tout ce qu'on peut leur faire faire
au collège la plupart du temps qu'on
reste désormais à apprivoiser ces
petites bêtes pour tenter de remporter
le challenge en mode game à rambouillet
le 15 mai prochain
un événement à ne pas manquer ce
week-end c'est léa est 15ème rencontre
internationale de capoeira art martial
brésilien
ça se passe samedi à elancourt dimanche
ça sera dans un autre département à
châtillon dans les hauts-de-seine
samedi ça se passe au complexe sportif
de l'europe à elancourt s'est organisée
par le groupe bel horizon de capoeira
d'elancourt bonsoir mr touchés bonsoir
vous êtes maître de capoeira fondateur
de ce club bello horizon que vous êtes
venus ce soir avec deux de vos élèves
votre fils talisman sorte à nice et nous
avons à ma gauche khadr bonsoir pris
hier soir alors on va parler bien sûr de
ces rencontres metz retouché on peut
dire c'est une grande fête de la
capoeira qui va se passer ce week end
oui bien sûr c'est un grande fête voilà
ça fait déjà c'est le quinzième
rencontre que j'ai engagé ici dans la
villa des champions aux champions et
aussi elancourt donc ces deux villes
différentes
donc ce sera beaucoup d'énergie beaucoup
de mettre beaucoup de professeurs et
beaucoup d'élèves
donc s'il fait qu'il faut pas manquer et
donc on rappelle le principe pendant ces
deux jours c'est des journées de stage
il ya aussi des démonstrations de deux
mètres de capoeira puisqu'il y aura
plusieurs grandes grand maître présents
pour cet événement
oui bien sûr au mur à plusieurs mètres
plusieurs pays comme didier ces
rencontres internationales donc on verra
des maîtres des madrid du brésil
berlin quand la une du sud de la france
reste la france un plus partout tant
qu'époux venir pour qu'on partage et
cette énergie avec nous donc venus du
monde entier je me tourne vers vos
élèves thalys pour commencer c'est
qu'elle ait la chance finalement sur ce
week-end de côtoyer ces grandes ces
grands maîtres
c'est une chance le medad oui ça prouve
qu'on peut leur montrer ce qu'on a
appris ces derniers temps ces dernières
années on les apprécie notre hymne aux
qui nous avons appris nouveau en fait
ils ont cette année c'est à dire votre
côté ça fait quoi de pouvoir côtoyer ces
grands maîtres sur ce week-end pour moi
en fait on prend de l'expérience quand
on côtoie des gens qui sont plus gras
des plus avancés dans la pratique et
donc c'est toujours l'expérience qu'on
cherche quand on est moins gradés si
vous vous savez ça fait quand même temps
vous faites de la capoeira
ça fait j'ai commencé à l'âge de 14 ans
et ça fait dix neuf ans 19 ans d'accord
qu'est ce qui vous a poussée au départ a
essayé cet art qui vient du brésil
ben j'ai commencé au collège j'ai
rencontré deux trois capoeiristes eh
ouais budam au moins j'ai commencé à
chercher un club autour de chez moi et
j'ai trouvé un club et petit à petit
j'ai rencontré m touché qui m'a formé
qui m'a permis de rentrer dans la
famille de la capoiera et et de
découvrir cet art magnifique c'est une
voile famille tallis viber ah oui et
vous pourquoi pourquoi vous avez suivi
les huîtres année pas de votre père fils
exactement j'ai suivi mon père et qui se
promet plein armements et je continue
alors la capoeira mais ce retouché si on
revient sur cet art finalement c'est un
art complexe qu'il ya du sport il ya ce
combat cette danse mais aussi plus
enraciné dans la culture brésilienne non
il ya un lien avec le chant brésilien un
lien aussi avec les instruments les
percussions qui nous viennent du brésil
c'est un art complet on va toucher à
tout exactement
donc la capoeira et pour moi c'était un
art complet quand j'ai commencé la
capoeira en place 10 nov 10
d'ici on n'est jamais arrêté j'ai
continué là j'ai pu servir et jusque là
j'ai continué à entraîner et à montrer
mes adhérents
qu'est ce que c'est là qu'a pu
rassembler un petit peu de tout le chant
la musique les paroles la langue
brésilienne
quand on monte en graciant quand on
continue sur plusieurs années c'est
important de savoir parler
ce portugais du brésil c'est important
bien sûr c'est important parce que la
commune continue à la pratique d'un
capteur à un bout d'un mois elle va
changer de grade et anglade qui est se
passe par exemple on brade instructeur
moniteurs et droit exactement parler en
plus de la langue déjà qu'on est à tenir
les chansons et joua les instruments que
c'est très important dans la capitale
et quand vous êtes arrivé en france
c'était il ya une quinzaine d'années
c'est ça pourquoi avoir eu envie de
transmettre cet art ici en france en
fait j'ai dit plusieurs reprises qui est
là c'est pas moi qui a choisi la france
marquant ce que m'a choisie dans la
france est mal choisi d'être ici
aujourd'hui et ça me fait un nombre
précis démontré à cette culture
brésilienne edit transmettre mon savoir
à mes adhérents au qui un jour aussi
pouvaient transmettre à ses adhérents
c'est à moi aussi sur les origines
forcément de la lacc après grâce à ça
vient de très loin c'est d origine
africaine ou au temps de l'esclavagé
c'est ça la caméra on vous avait dit que
ces afro brésilienne c'est est grave
africa que c'était l'époque ramené à
l'aller la vigne est allé au brésil
et donc là bas sané césium descendance
des esclaves qui ont plié la capoeira au
brésil et c'est une manière de pouvoir
s'entraîner sans avoir sans être menacé
de représailles c'est ça parce que on se
battait pas vraiment c'était c'était un
entraînement au combat mais voilà il n'y
avait pas ça ne pouvait le faire de ça
permettait de le faire de manière cachée
en fait
laquelle peut rester coincée s'est
déguisé en danse d'accord ce qui on
pouvait aller jusqu'à ne fait pas le
montrer à les patrons qu'est-ce qui
était en harmonie et là il s'est déguisé
en danse et du coup ils ont commencé à
utiliser qui s'appelle le tambour qui
aujourd'hui on appelle diatta bac de
côté pour qu'ils puissent jouer la
musique chanter comme l'époque ne
pouvait pas les communiqués qui savait
pas comment on allait parler entre eux
pendant que du coup ils ont trouvé cela
le champ on sait communiquer à travers
d'un de la bac et le chant du coup en
cachette de cela est montré que c'était
ils pouvaient se toucher vraiment mais
enfin à dévoiler patron non elle a donc
là c'était la danse qu'on n'est pas très
envie d embêter après les pour
danser et donc la plus tard bien pieters
a désigné le nombre captera qui sait en
guadeloupe y aura ni que c'est vous dire
à des indiens du brésil on ne reste
qu'une minute dans cet entretien petit
tour de table
qu'est ce que vous attendez de ces
rencontres khadr qui est qu'est-ce qui
voit là qu'est ce que vous attendez de
ces rencontres samedi et dimanche elle a
déjà avant tout on
bien s'amuser on va rencontrer d'autres
capoeiristes qui viennent d'autres
régions on va communiquer ou au bout
d'un moment on va en voit sûrement s'est
lié d'amitié et pouvoir nous aussi aller
dans d'autres rencontres dans quelques
mois ou quelques semaines ali souhaite
enrichir ça va être un vrai jeu est là
pour s'amuser montrer notre nouvelle
expérience les côtés du club bel horizon
de qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est ce qu'on
attend du monde j'imagine
moi j'attends beaucoup de monde chaque
année roi c'est différent il ya plus de
monde qu'ils ont à cette année on a un
peu près déjà dans centaine d adhérents
ici dans 78 comme dit l'abbé rosen cap
laurens un peu partout le dimanche le
92è centaines dans plupart disent lassés
des enfants on doit qui verra de la
famille cody la capture à six familles
et donc des raisons captera la famille
heureuse capoeira on vit tous à venir
partager un vrai coeur en bonne ambiance
en branle couture brésilienne et voir
profiter bien donc là c'est ça que je
vais vous montrer et j'espère qu'ils
j'ai volé soit merci à vous d'avoir été
avec nous et les rencontres
internationales de capoeira ge rappelle
c'est ce samedi au complexe sportif de
l'europe
l encours et ça sera le dimanche dans un
autre département à châtillon dans le 92
avant de se quitter focus sur des
créations made in france mais à la durée
limitée
c'est le principe d'une boutique à
versailles ouverte depuis un an et demi
les clients peuvent y découvrir toutes
les deux semaines de nouveaux produits
un concept revisité de boutiques
éphémères qui semble avoir trouvé son
public camille lambert au rayon des
pochettes de la décoration ou encore des
vêtements pour enfants tous les objets
que vous trouverez à capsules market
sont faits main autre particularité ils
sont renouvelés tous les quinze jours on
permet aux créateurs d'avoir un espace
restreint dont peu cher pendant un durée
une durée limitée donc peu cher aussi
pour eux donc c'est pas un gros coup et
ça leur permet en fait de développer et
de se faire connaître
depuis son lancement la boutique a
accueilli 250 créateurs un concept qui
les séduit moi je suis jeune créatrice
je vend principalement sur internet est
donc là le fait d'être en bout
de rencontrer ses clients voilà c'est
une chance énorme qu'elle nous offre
moi je crée dans mon appartement donc
c'est vraiment une opportunité de
pouvoir le présenter au public
et puis voilà de rencontrer sa clientèle
de rencontrer d'autres créateurs en plus
des créations que vous pouvez trouver
ici capsule market propose également des
expositions carte de fidélité et carte
cadeaux seront bientôt proposés aux
clients
un an et demi après l'ouverture de cette
boutique le bilan est positif
on commence à voir une vraie clientèle
très fidèle et puis quelque chose de
très positif aussi pour nous c'est que
depuis maintenant six mois après on a
des créateurs qui nous demande même de
venir exposer alors que jusqu'ici
c'était à nous d'aller chercher passé
énormément de temps sur les réseaux
sociaux des créateurs qui seront encore
plus nombreux à proposer leurs produits
pour 2018 les clients pourront découvrir
tous les quinze jours le travail d'une
vingtaine d'exposants
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal
retrouvez-nous en replay sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile tv
78 demain vendredi c'est au tour du 7-8
l'hebdo avec nicolas kirillovitch n on
se donne rendez-vous lundi pour une
nouvelle semaine d'information locale
sur tv 78 belle soirée à tous
[Musique]